dave what was the tipping point for you
to leave california like if you were to
say
well the tipping point was five years
ago but i finally made a decision today
or was it like covet i'm done i'm sick
of it let's start looking at different
places and then you looked at tennessee
texas and florida and you said i'm gonna
go to florida yeah so i moved to la in
2013. uh we had about a thousand bucks
from new york
from new york so i'm a true new yorker
born in brooklyn grew up in long island
i went to suny binghamton i lived in
manhattan most of my life so really the
only two places as an adult that i've
lived until these last three months were
new york city and la and yet the ideas
that i talk about are the stuff that
people care about in the middle of the
country so i don't know what happened i
don't know what happened i had these two
coasts and somehow my ideas kind of kind
of came to them when you moved from new
york to la did you come with that new
york you know coastal ideology to oh
yeah i was i was a lefty i worked i
worked for the young turks i was a
bernie supporter all of that all that
all that stuff it's all it's true all of
it
as han solo said yeah it was all true um
but there were a couple moments i mean
look the the two years of covid
demolished los angeles los angeles is a
shell of itself hollywood has been
destroyed okay so i could do all the
basic stuff the crime the homelessness
is the drug but
i'll tell you what the final moment was
the final straw and i had been thinking
about it for about a year
back and forth could i do it where was i
going to go nashville
dallas etc
i campaigned with larry elder for the
for the recall so i was opening on stage
with him and tor you know going out
there and meeting people and it was
amazing it was incredible you know they
called him the black face of white
supremacy that's what the l.a sometimes
article yeah
it felt like an onion headline by the
way or a babylon onion isn't even that
good uh a young woman who threw an egg
at him in the gorilla mask that always i
thought somehow the media didn't pick
that one up you know it's like it was
just extraordinary anyway i'm out there
with this guy and there was such energy
i met so many good people they were not
far right they weren't even
conservatives most of them were liberals
they were california liberals who were
mugged by reality they were just good
decent people who suddenly their
restaurants were closed their kids were
locked down all of this stuff anyway the
recall obviously was a disaster
and three days after the recall do you
want the exact moment your head is your
mind is going to explode three days
after the recall i got audited by the
state
that makes sense yeah and i said we have
you've never been audited before i've
never been audited before my my stuff's
all clean it's sure it's all fine
we take very good care of all my
businesses um three days after got that
immediately
like literally i think i hung up the
phone and i called my real estate agent
i said get me out of here and we put the
we did that house privately
i sold it in three weeks basically and
then i had to really quickly figure out
i always felt that it was going to be
florida uh but you know i love the the
blaze guys and i do some stuff with them
and glenn beck and glenn really wanted
me in dallas so i had a little moment of
that i loved the daily wire guys and
candace and ben and so i did look at one
house in nashville but i am so happy to
be here and i'm
i'm really like as i said i'm reborn
here i feel you feel it here in florida
it's free and you said you said
something prior to shooting you said i
love florida i don't know you could
curse if you want yeah there was an f in
there yeah no i i often love florida
it's it's not just
it's not just the the politics of it
that that's good it's what it's doing to
the people
uh you know i don't know when the last
time you guys just went back to new york
or went to cali or just went to some of
these blue cities he's from california
yeah yeah no i know so but i don't know
have you been there just in the last
couple months like
i went to la
to shoot a prageru video about a month
ago i said to my guys i will fly in go
to the studio and get me the hell out of
there even though the prageru studio is
a half mile from my house i guess it
would have been nice to go look at it
again or something it was a disaster i
got asked for a vaccine passport to go
to coffee bean and tea leaf
uh that makes sense just everything
about it it's rotten and then even just
the greenery the greenery in florida is
beautiful and wonderful in the trees and
then you go to la and everything's dying
and dead and brown it's uh
what the hell am i being clear about
this uh yeah i'm very happy here and i
don't like that place by the way what
was the reason why you chose florida
over dallas and nashville you know it's
partly i think because of my well first
off i have some family here and we
hadn't had been in a state with family
for a long time most i'm from new york
as i said so most of my family's east
coast my folks have a place in florida
my sister lives in miami with her
husband and kids
also because of the tech side of things
obviously miami is just exploding right
now in the tech world so i wanted to be
close to that but at a political level
you know for me as someone that came
from the left and you know i have mostly
libertarian views but i don't mind
calling myself a conservative now
there's a wide thing right hat right now
happening on the right you know you got
the disaffected lefties and the
libertarians then you've got the you
know sort of evangelical or the
christian conservatives there really is
this movement of trying to figure out
can this thing really hold because there
are a lot of people that have different
beliefs serious beliefs that are very
different i felt the stuff that i care
about the most it's working here in
florida meaning it's a little more of a
secular conservatism as opposed to you
go to nashville or you go to texas it's
a little more religious that's not
necessarily my thing i felt that the
ideas that i really care about can
flourish a little bit more here so it
was it was a series of things you know
the weather is good and all that stuff
tell him with the reasons you wanted to
go to florida he was from l.a he was in
dallas i mean he's got some very good
jobs listen i knew we were moving out of
la
in 2012 2013 when he moved to plano and
he moved to plano says beautiful yeah so
he says you got to start looking into
texas i'm also a california refugee i
came in 13 to texas yeah and look at us
yeah look at us now i came i came to
florida in 1980 guys so when he was i
was born here he's brought my nice try
no but yeah but you know so at that time
i started looking at everything but
being middle eastern everybody it's
tough to leave your family
mom dad sister friends restaurants
things your cod went to glendale high
school so do i want to leave this you
know relationships i got and i started
looking and i said nope i cannot build
an insurance company being headquartered
out of california no way in the world so
i looked at central for me it was
important to go to texas because i
travel a lot we have a couple hundred
150 offices nationwide so if i'm going
to la three hours three hours three
hours three hours florida would have
been six and back in the time difference
la would have been six and back and time
difference so dallas made the most most
sense because i was traveling a ton if
somebody's building a national business
i don't think florida or california
makes sense i think the best spot to be
in is a dallas is a houston is in austin
if you travel a ton and then so we moved
to houston we moved to dallas we lived
in plano for a few years
and then we were right by addison our
headquarters was in addison and then
gradually when covet hit i started
looking i said we gotta look at
tennessee
nashville i lived in tennessee for two
years when i was in the army and i said
why are they gonna stay here in dallas
but then i love the water i love the
water the ocean california i mean i just
love that right and i said listen if
california and texas had a baby it would
be florida so that was the best
combination to come to florida we've
been here now for what 14 months 13
months 14 months and i'm in love just as
much as you are i got to tell you so
people always say to me
is there anything you don't like i
honestly cannot think of anything yes i
could complain about the traffic a
little bit but i lived in new york and
l.a so no i'm not gonna is there
anything anything so okay let's let's do
it let's be uh okay we haven't really
experienced a hurricane yet okay so i
don't know what a hurricane looks like
i've been through tornado i've been
through wars i've been through
earthquakes yeah okay we'll see what the
hurry at least hurricane gives you a
warning earthquake does not tornadoes
don't give you too much of a warning
hurricane you know for two or three days
that something's coming right plus it
was raining fire in l.a yeah come on
literally well dave
you moved here to january yeah iguanas
you got to give iguanas
iguanos are not vicious but
i want to revisit this exact
conversation in august and august and
september i get it my hair is going to
be a little flatter
dave i get it okay so if there's nine
months out of the year this is the best
place to be in the world period full
stop yeah three months out of the year
go anywhere else that's my opinion so
every summer i would travel i was here
for that and it's hot as hell here
that's okay it did not bother me when i
was your fourth oh you're from around
pat yeah yeah
that's a good point right there oh you
know
i'm at a party with pat it was last year
at the bitcoin conference uh it was in
june last year and it was hot out we
were at that party outdoors people are
sweating pat's wearing a jacket yeah
yeah zero i'm like this guy can
withstand anything it's chilly yeah
exactly yeah you want to take the jacket
off at i'm good yeah so if you would
stand the heat like with anything they
could take the heat forget about the
weather what was that conference about
that was about a mayor of a major united
states city coming out and in favor of
crypto and trying to attract uh
innovators and entrepreneurs to come to
his to come to a city shout out to
sweden so forget about the exactly mayor
suarez is another reason that florida is
so wonderful i grew up here i had i had
about four years here in high school my
dad's job moved us here but i was born
and raised in california basically and
we were here there was a republican
governor his name was bob graham
but if you take a look at like a one to
ten and a tennisberry goldwater and a
one is bernie bob graham was like
exactly a five and he was trying to
build jobs he was trying to be not so
tourist and transitory you know the
snowbirds and so the seeds of this went
florida i think go back to 1980 and
there's guys like charlie crist and now
desantis that have been faithful to it
and they haven't screwed it up by trying
to go way one way or the other and i
think that's one of the benefits and
then suarez rises up
hispanic mayor representing every kid
that can wake up in miami in the morning
and say i could be mayor i could be
mayor look at that you know i was at an
event uh last night at uh keith reboy's
house and you know keith was the one
that originally sent the tweet that
suarez responded how can i help which
basically caused the influx i mean i
would say par part of the reason i'm
here is because of that so i was at this
event at rabois last night and suarez
was there and he gave a talk
and i'm standing there watching the guy
and i've met him a couple times i
interviewed him once and i'm thinking
man this is so the reverse 180 reverse
of what i was dealing with in la eric
eric garcetti was destroying actively
destroying and we can go okay
were the intentions good or not that
that's an interesting conversation i
don't think the intentions are good
actually i think they are intentionally
doing this stuff but i'm listening to
suarez he's talking about how they want
to be this international city that will
be the hub of crypto and the new economy
and they want to be 30 years ahead of
america when it comes to all of this
other stuff and because the federal
government is so screwy we just have to
do what we think is right and then last
week i did a prageru event where where
desantis spoke and all desantis says is
basic honesty it's not that he's out
there saying the most crazy stuff that's
riling people up in reality he's
basically saying honest decent stuff
which is revolutionary in 2022. and it's
just such a stark difference man from
from la and i know i'm preaching to the
choir yeah what was this event last
night at keith's house what was that he
just had like a little salon for bitcoin
conference so it was a lot of the the
tech bros and that was our good friend
jack abraham there i don't know
you know jack the pump
oh the pomp was there
the pomp shows up in shorts everyone
else everyone i'm feeling very i'm
feeling very underdressed today but
everyone else is decked out we had
dinner with pomp the other night yeah
the only person in shorts i love pop
he's a great guy jack because he can
yeah yeah adam's got a
anyways we were at this place
and it's 12 of us
a friend of mine ken golden the owner of
golden auctions who
sold 41 million dollars of cards
collectible cards last month is what he
did yeah and they're showing are you
telling me i shouldn't have sold my
baseball card no you shouldn't you
shouldn't 1987 to my buddy evan for 400
bucks the whole thing
i think i had pete rose rookie or get
out of here
hey pete rose 73 mvp i wonder what
that's worth right now well depends
everything is about grading right now
but we're sitting there having dinner
and ken's trying to get me to uh bid on
these two pieces he has one of them is a
jackie robinson game warren jersey from
the 30s for him a million dollars and
then he had a uh he had a uh
uh uh was it superman issue number one
yeah for 10 million and that's 10
million as well issue number one it was
a great at eight and a half wow but i
did make a
few bids on what the willie mays rookie
the the leo messi rookie and the 86
floor box that we had on but anyways one
guy's sitting here we're having dinner
and he says yeah i have one of the holy
grail cards okay what do you have he
says i have a honest wagner sgc5 oh
that's like it right isn't that the card
but an sgc5 i said how much is an sgc5
it's about 25 million bucks okay cool so
he's got a 25 million dollars gc5 uh in
the corner sgc3 honest wagner t206
everybody there had card collections
and then palm shows up and pom's not a
card guy yeah it's a bitcoin max
well maybe ninety percent he's right and
he starts and he shows him in his black
shorts black shirt his black shirt
that's his suit that's his cool dude
though really yeah
really cool cat but uh you're gonna see
him in those meetings he'll come in and
pop in and pop out if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you